hey theo hey brendan it's savannah from
out here in southern idaho
um i have a little bit of a debate club
slash relationship advice for you
yes i'll move in with you me and my
boyfriend of four years
just decided to part ways
after i was ready to be wifed up and he
decided
he didn't want to wife me up so i'm
going through a little bit of a rut
wondering if i should just keep it tight
and look for that forever or if i should
have a whole face
so debate club ho phase or keep it tight
and look for that ride or die
i'm only 24 so it's not a huge deal
right now i know
everybody's telling me not to rush it i
want to see what you guys think
so thank you and brennan i'd love to see
you again
we met a few years ago at the wise guys
comedy club and that was pretty cool
um theo i'd love to see you for the
first time so get your ass to the west
coast
thanks guys gang gang buzz buzz dude 24
[ __ ] hoard up for 5 000 alex
i think give you 24 i think uh
what was the question again i think he's
sliding some dallas cowboys dms you feel
me like get wild
girl especially that body like start
living man it's a disgrace if you don't
well i don't know much but i would say
this that i think the chances of you
getting out there and having a nice time
outside of a relationship are probably
pretty good
i think you could meet a good farming
man too
especially if she's out there where she
said idaho yep
get out there in nampa they got a place
called namp out there where they make uh
tomatoes not tomatoes but um squat not
squash but um
potatoes no sugar beets oh those are
nice
i think she should get out of idaho and
get to vegas or somewhere and
dude just let loose girl she's growing a
set of sugar beets of her own
you know what i'm saying i can't tell if
it's the video the way yeah i can't
lighting is on the video
hush puppies or something
i can't tell you that's what i'm
thinking dude she has some
[Music]
bongers yeah
what do you mean i could have a baby i
could have a
baby she's the type of girl chin would
take out and black out on saki
oh yes it looks like each one of her
breasts just ate a big
sandwich dude that's what it looks like
dude he has some definitely
corn fed hitters oh she's got those
jersey mics
baby you feel me mike check
dude i would say yelling each one of
those yeah
i'd freaking try to hide one of those in
my mouth oh yeah
you know what i'm saying and then
freaking call the cops on myself and i
choked to death
breaking news uh theo just added a show
on boise
yeah what about you neck nipple what do
you think when you see that girl huh
honestly i'm thinking of moving to
indiana now i don't know wherever she is
go to indianapolis
yeah she's a baddie
[Music]
is